which is the
you just went
then
right
um
hopefully because
now so many
so obviously you sound like I'm sure
enough but if you are again I'm talking
about straight guys
that's the way did you say that you
think are you saying that
Magnum
s
especially as a guy
yeah I mean there are central people
it doesn't mean it's not the right for
you because you like to do that
is
guys
in order to attract care
wait some
especially nowadays looking good it
doesn't mean
to you
you know he was self-confidence
you're going to do things but and and
that's the same thing for gas there is a
majority of girls they think in the very
good looking which is nothing wrong with
the confidence of it but to me the as an
ugly guy as I Define myself because I
was a man work in the fashion industry
right so I know what good looking is and
what
right they're thinking they're good
looking if you are again online and
people give you money just to see you
all the fun or even Tick Tock it doesn't
mean good looking you just call a bunch
of loser right they don't want to
interact in the society that's what the
society want they make you to do that
right so
you're working as a dating advisor I
didn't get it yeah yeah so you know I
think a change right even 2007 me in the
past it used to be good editing so you
get the first date but even on the first
date you need to show you were
interested to the girl so you at least
have to have to try to kiss it doesn't
mean no physically you have to kiss her
but she needs to know yeah you're
interested because if she doesn't see
that it's finished no I agree the second
time you got to go for it because uh
it's most as such it's not my surgery
because you won't have a third time
unless did you get consent first of
course you always have questions how is
that concerned somehow I never use drugs
or alcohol relationship you know I'm
quite clear but unless she's really
interested you won't have a third time
well no you're right you've got to show
your room yeah you've got to show your
retirement up front for sure but that
thing about there's something about if
you're if you're a guy and you've
recently been sexually successful it
seems like women can sense that on you
somehow yeah yeah and then they and then
positive why but yeah yeah yeah and then
you're more likely to be selected again
so it kind of Builds on itself doesn't
it men with limited options they worship
you they kiss the ground that you walk
on and it's very off-putting yeah or
they they just treat you like you're
like God and you can do no wrong it's
like it's like you'll be kind of an
[ __ ] and they're like okay you're
beautiful anyway you're like what so are
you saying that you guys would like piss
man off on purpose just to see them
absolutely I mean it's it's like
conscious I just think like when we do
[ __ ] tests we're women I could just see
all the black pill guys
like oh my God no I can explain it right
because it sounds bad which honestly you
know just be happy that there's like
women that are being honest um now I
don't think that it's a always like
conscious like I found myself in my
marriage the only time that I do it and
it's very few and far between it's like
I I'll ask my husband for something I'm
like it's a 50 50 shot he's gonna get it
for me I'm like can you give me a glass
of water knowing I have two feet you
know what I mean and he'll look at me
he'd be like what are you doing I'm like
oh just kidding I'll just get my own
glass of water
um but otherwise you got it though now
what but I think the hand I don't I
don't know my I think my husband is just
very much like you know I'm pregnant
right now so if I was like nine months
pregnant I think he would do it for me
but I think that man looks at me and
he's like you're not really tired like
you're messing with me go and get that
glass of water yourself but in terms of
uh like I think why women do it is
because if you can fold to me the woman
in your life who you need to protect
then you can fold to the world and I
need a man that's going to be able to
protect me so I think that's a little
bit why women will do things like that
but the glass of water thing is just
something that like we got we got back
we gotta back up on that and get it we
gotta flesh it out so you're saying that
if you think that your man will fold to
you yes that he will be like basically
soft when he's out in the world yes and
then it's probably going to be a risk so
you don't want him to fold to you no
essentially no
no text right so you know
um look at my first trimester and
wrapping it up and you know I've been
very tired and exhausted and so my
husband will go and he'll make a meal
for me or he'll like get a meal for me
and things like that it's very
contextual but no I I don't want a yes
man and a lot of women have had
experiences with Yes Man I mean we know
that women have leverage I'm sure
Pearl's had experiences with yes men too
it's not fun it's not cute and you know
that's that's the thing it's like it's
very interesting for men because if we
ask for something else we say something
we actually mean it you know I mean like
generally men will be like okay this
this this and that's what I want my
women be like this this this is he gonna
do it yeah
I mean like we don't actually it's
partially like unconscious I'm just
smart enough and aware enough to tell
when I'm doing it I was just thinking
though I can imagine all the all the
haters in the chat be like sort of like
oh my God like like it's it's women
actually sitting and complaining about
guys doing things that are nice for them
oh my God like he was too nice oh he
bought me this glass of water can a girl
be too nice as many of you know I was
just ban and on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible